pfd live continues on this thursday
morning as we
try to understand how the current unrest
in sports will or won't affect the
national football league the lions the
first team in the nfl to shut down a
practice over the shooting of jacob
blake that happened on sunday joining us
now mike tarico the host of nbc's
football night in america and mike you
live in the detroit area i i when i
heard the lions that canceled practice
on tuesday i just assumed there was a
covet 19 outbreak i i was both stunned
and and awed
by the decision of a football team with
limited practices anyway and limited
time to get ready for the start of the
season shut it down for a full day
because of what happened so they could
let the world know that this is not
acceptable
mike i'm with you great to see you guys
miss all being together and i think the
being together part of that
shouldn't be
run over matthew stafford if you listen
closely at his comments talked about
that was the first time they've had that
conversation all together all in the
same room because some of these
conversations happened during the zoom
calls uh during covet 19 and all of that
so the power of it had to be
really impactful in the room and full
credit here to bob quinn the gm of the
lions
and matt patricia their head coach
those are
two guys who you know we know the
pressure that's on the franchise the
organization to perform but but you know
the they're really good and decent
people and they're trying to find a way
to lead in this uncharted time and i
give them full credit for taking this
step because like you said mike i
thought it was covet 19 and then i was
thinking wow to give up a day of
practice when every rep matters right
now uh is pretty significant but this is
a significant topic and it's one that if
you uh turn the other way you're going
to get hit on the other side of the road
by it you have to face this head-on for
these teams in these organizations and
listen to your players and in the long
run this may have been the best thing
that they did
mike you're one of the most
well-thought-out caring people i've ever
been around and if i ever had to make a
big decision in my life i truly mean
this you'd be one of the five people i
would call to ask for advice for so
i ask you this just to go like where do
we go from here i just want to hear like
you know mike tarico's take on this and
where sports go with all the social
injustice matters going on and kind of
your thought on all of it
i appreciate you saying that chris um
i don't know because i i'm not in the
shoes of those athletes a lot of those
guys
are speaking from the heart and from
personal experience a lot of those
players are speaking in fear of what's
going to happen
with their kids i haven't been in that
situation so i can't
give proper perspective to their voice i
do think as i watch the nba guys
in general okay just in general
by playing they keep the message front
and center
and that's not me saying i want to see
the nba playoffs finish
that's not going to change my life or
any of your lives
i just think that if they go back to
their communities we may not be paying
as much attention to what they are
saying
as we will if it's after
a game-winning shot or a great nba
playoff game most of the players have
been very good about using that platform
continually in the bubble after a game
answer about the game and then tag the
answer with we're not losing sight of
the main reason that we are all doing
this it's to continue to bring attention
to the racial
divide the social injustice those other
issues so
my gut
i'll let you go chris my gut would be if
they don't play they may lose the power
of the platform that they are using
right now yeah that that's interesting
and i'm happy to hear you say that
because it's something mike and i talked
about on the in the first segment you
know and and and mike argued too and i
understand his side of this that you
know the players have been doing this
and here we're still in the same
situation but maybe there maybe there
needs to be a more aggressive approach
every time like every time a mike's in
front of you whatever that is yeah when
lebron james is holding up the
championship trophy you're right so okay
so you think that's still the best voice
basically going forward is to be there
be on tv performing having people
watching and that's the best way to get
the message as is compared to just
boycotting and saying you know we're not
going to play and and do that
yeah chris i i think so just in general
but i'm removed again i don't feel the
pain we saw the mets player at the
podium in tears last night uh we saw
players who have shared their story of
being in these situations
it's a personal painful story to tell so
for everyone out there it's not the same
feeling as we have removed from the
situation so i always want to make sure
that i say that just my opinion in
general we're gonna hear football
players when this becomes part of their
conversation when the nfl season starts
in a couple of weeks and we're going to
hear basketball players in the playoffs
etc etc
and mike my point was basically there's
only so much talking that can be done
before the players conclude that the
ears are deaf how much do we have to do
how much do we have to say how much do
our coaches have to give heartfelt sound
bites at press conferences instead of
talking about basketball issues before
change happens and i guess that's where
i'm at a loss how do we even get to the
point where we can measure the changes
happen there's no finish line here the
finish line is stop it
and
there's never a point where we're going
to be able to declare victory because
we're always one news cycle away from
the next video of an unarmed black man
being shot by police
you're right mike but how can you make
that
uh happen less often to be very candid
how does that happen it happens with
legislation it happens with education it
happens first with listening and i think
if we go back to the george floyd
protest what's one of the big things
that we all learned we need to listen
we've been given two ears and one mouth
we should listen twice as much as we
talk i've done more listening than i
have about this issue in the past by a
wide margin i think most of the people
watching the show have
i think that's a big part of the change
that's happening right now now here's
the next portion to me uh lebron james
has 70 million followers on instagram 40
million on twitter i'm sure there's some
co-mingling of those numbers right but
those 80 or 90 people who follow lebron
james on social media
can they be activated as true followers
what do i mean
voting how they vote actions that are
taken demands for legislation look once
a politician gets elected what do they
want to do they want to get elected
again so how do you do that you win
constituents support how do you do that
by supporting causes when people pick up
the phone and they say hey support this
bill about body cam support this bill
about proper police techniques changes
and techniques so when that happens at
the grassroots level then there is that
change you're talking about mike that's
not happening right now so can these
players use the platform in the cities
where by the way most of them have never
been until they got signed or drafted by
those teams can they do that to leave a
legacy of change in those cities that's
where the players can really use their
platform to make a bit of a difference
do you have a a sense or a feel of what
you think the nfl should do here to back
players i mean
or do you ha do you think nfl players
will threaten to skip games i mean i
know you don't know the answers to these
things but you know again just would
like to hear your take on on that yeah
well the template's out there now right
it's happened it's happened in a variety
of places bubble or not
coved or not uh so they've certainly
opened the door you know players players
didn't used to uh celebrate in a certain
way until they saw other players do it
right people didn't tweet their feelings
to post game until they saw other people
do it now everybody does it so once the
door is open it gives everybody the
opportunity to follow so that is
certainly out there i think if i'm nfl
management this morning if i'm
leadership in the league
i'm making sure that i'm having real
conversations with the leadership of our
players and finding out what's the
temperature what's the conversation like
how do we make a difference as your
partner i think we'll see the league
making very significant moves to be true
partners with the players here in trying
to support their cause and use this
platform that more people watch than any
other entertainment vehicle in the
country in national football league
games i think we're going to see that
happen as this season goes on the
question will become when we have a
bridge like this to cross
how do we go about it and how does it
get done one thing that wasn't impacted
yesterday there were no fans in the
stands because of the bubble right
so what happens if fans are left back
into stadiums and something like this
happens then you do run a larger risk of
disappointing your customers and at the
end of the day for all of us
we may do this because we're journalists
or we may do this because we're analysts
or for business reasons we are
consumers and customers we are the
people who have to deliver product to
the customers as broadcasters as players
as a league so if you start to lose your
customers you have to be concerned about
that
and mike it was just yesterday morning
that chris and i spent an extended
amount of time trying to reconcile
roger goodell's recent comments to
emmanuel ocho in the uncomfortable
conversations with the black man series
about supporting players unconditionally
unequivocally if they choose to kneel
during the national anthem
with this effort by jerry jones to
thread a needle that has gotten smaller
the camel is larger and the needle is
smaller over the last 24 hours
how do you think this is going to play
out with the cowboys because i
personally think the nfl needs to tell
jerry you have to step back and let your
players decide what they want to do
without any type of director and direct
interference
yeah that's going to be a one that
absolutely bears watching mike and
that's going to be one that they're
going to have to deal with directly and
i'm sure not just jerry jones but
ownership around the national football
league is going to be put into a
different light just like mba ownership
is now the bucks ownership didn't know
found out said they supported mark cuban
has come out in support of the nba board
of governors so their owners their
meeting this morning at 11 o'clock the
nba has certainly been a more
progressive league than the other
leagues but i think as we see more
people following the lead of the mba
it's going to put pressure on the other
leads in every group from the players to
the league office to the ownership of
how they respond to these situations
times have changed it is very different
now than it was nine months ago or six
months ago and that's not just with
covet 19. that is with the true
conversations that have been being had
about race in america and nfl owners if
they want to continue to have a game
that prosper they're going to have to
deal with this directly within their
buildings and with each other i i think
the league office has pushed their
farther than i really imagined they
would in such a quick time and i applaud
them for the things i've heard them say
and the plans that they are putting in
place for this coming season now it's
gonna be up to ownership in these cities
to continue to follow up in that path
and mike you mentioned the influence
that lebron james has over basketball in
football even though he's only been on
the field for 31 regular season games
patrick mahomes is becoming
for a variety of reasons he's got the
charisma right he can and he will say
what he believes and it just it and it
comes across well i do you see him
emerging
as we get deeper and deeper into these
issues as the nfl's primary voice when
it comes to these matters of social
justice
he might because of his youth and
because of his accomplishment all at the
same time like you said at the end the
nfl is a league where predominantly the
star players have been the white
quarterbacks and now here's patrick
mahomes and lamar jackson those players
have helped
change the conversation you don't really
talk and players before that obviously
like donovan mcnabb and before that
randall cunningham we go on and on but
certainly we're seeing more
african-american quarterbacks play in
the nfl and doug maro what you say the
quarterback's the most popular guy in
the room in the national football league
so because of all those things yes he
has been delivered to this point
you don't have to say you have to act
like lebron james to be worthy of being
the voice or face of the league
sometimes that's put on you and it takes
time to mold into that so
he's been thoughtful about everything
he's done so far i'm sure he'll be
thoughtful about this but there are also
veteran voices in the league have been
around i think those players together
can help the patrick mahomes or the new
players of this era to be a loud voice
that video that came out during the year
you know pushed by malcolm thomas in the
video that went viral and post george
floyd that was significant patrick
mahomes inclusion in that helped give it
a lot of its traction so those are some
of the players i think who we're going
to be watching as this season starts how
do they lead their teams and how much is
their voice heard publicly in these
conversations yeah that's right it's
going to take quarterbacks guys like
mahomes to further this conversation and
make society wake up a little bit um all
right let's go do another issue pandemic
football all right i mean for one are
you you know optimistic here as we get
closer and closer to the start of the
regular season and two i'd love to get
your
you know feel or thoughts on
the competitive conversation right now
the fans in the stadium the fake crowd
noise where that like how do you want to
see football played with no fans in the
stands or this competitive imbalance
yeah we could we could do three hours on
this guys and there's so many different
roads to go down let's start with what
the league has done i think the league
has done everything possible to get to
the starting line
and i applaud the players and obviously
all the folks start with dr alan sills
leading the medical effort for the
league and on through all the athletic
trainers and the people who are handling
this within each building the effort is
massive every day and we all see any of
us who've gone back to work or been in a
situation where work is happening the
effort to just make sure it's as safe
workplace as possible is extraordinary
and the measures that the league is
taking and the things that they are
thought about about how the competition
can take place i think the league
because of its resources and its
organization and the fact that they had
the longest runway of any of the pro
sports they're going to get to the
starting line i candidly would have
loved to have seen the players come a
friday
after testing was done have a mini
bubble not asking you to stay away from
your families for the whole week but
from friday through sunday even if
you're at home to treat it as such uh to
have somebody some confidence that
everyone who tested negative on thursday
or friday is competing on sunday and has
been in some sort of a a bubble so you
don't have to worry about that as much i
i i know there are there are some issues
with that i've raised that to some folks
within the league but that's something i
thought may have put the players in more
of a comfortable area
in terms of the competition this is
going to be an unfair year
nobody will be
given a lot of
pillows to lean on when you say this
wasn't fair for me this year
this has been fair for no one
no one's going to care that our jobs are
going to be tougher to do football night
in america or if notre dame plays to
call notre dame games nobody cares
everybody's life is tougher you're going
to have to deal with it and figure it
out if you have to play a game in front
of 10 000 then your state won't have
fans for two or four weeks it stinks
that's a bummer you gotta overcome it
yeah you gotta overcome people have won
road games in this league on the biggest
stages in the most important games so
you got to go in a road game with a
little bit of crowd noise but to me
that's not a big deal as far as the
ambient sound being played in the
stadium i'm just going to lean back on
what the baseball guys have said that
they they got used to it it's odd when
you hear noise you don't see people but
afterwards it it's worked out okay it's
been odd doing tv like this
but after a while we figured it out and
you know even with you sims it's
somewhat watchable
so
we i need to laugh it's always serious
stuff for two hours so
we we need some of this in life and i
think i think the coaches who tell their
guys right away guys the whole equity in
the national football league it's going
to be fair even playing field that might
not be the case that is not an excuse
this year the team that sets that tone
within their locker room is going to
have a much better chance of hitting the
curve ball when it's thrown at them
and mike one thing that fans need to get
comfortable with is the possibility
that when we conclude the regular season
there won't have been 256 games
and some teams will not have played 16
others will have played 16
and there may be some awkward playoff
positioning based on winning percentage
not based on gross wins and gross losses
and that's just going to be one of these
additional factors where yes it's not
fair but nothing's going to be fair this
year
let me channel my inner florio find a
conspiracy theories find the uh the
oddest route out there
mike what happens if there's a
quarantine in a state and it's a
division opponent and there will be no
travel waiver you can't come from a hot
spot state x to our state to play a game
and you may have to go to a neutral site
to play what would have been your home
game
and that's the game that might decide
your division could happen again
you cannot say it's not fair this isn't
the way it happened in 2007 when i came
in the league as an assistant coach
nobody's going to care this year the
league the league has set up a good
committee they've set up a bunch of
folks who know football who are going to
be out there trying to make sure that
whenever possible it's fair and balanced
it probably won't be and that's going to
be something you have to deal with look
football what do we hear chris you've
lived this with a thousand coaches what
do we hear all the time about football
it's the unexpected it's improvised and
adjust lee corso when i worked with him
would always tell us guys you gotta
improvise and adjust this is the
all-time improvise and adjust season the
team that is ready for that i think is
going to save a lot of stress and
anxiety worrying about what was me i can
only worry with what i can only deal
with one conspiracy mike all right so
like chill out all right i mean gosh i
gotta deal with this guy every day now
you oh god
i i was i was with you mike until you
until you used the word artist then i
wasn't quite sure whether or not it was
a compliment or not but you know to your
point
this is not unprecedented we've had
weather issues right when katrina hit
new orleans in 2005 and the saints were
supposed to host the giants what
happened the giants hosted the saints
and then the saints played wherever they
could find a field the rest of the
season the vikings had their roof
collapsed they played a home game
against the giants in detroit right so
the nfl has shown that it's willing to
be flexible when it has to be it's just
there's going to be a lot of potential
flexibility that gets crammed into one
football season
and and that's why i think you saw
commissioner goodell put together that
group that committee of folks who
represent different parts of the
football world uh for those exact issues
and how do we address them going forward
and chris you brought up a point and i
was going to get to it and then my
answer got off the rails and long-winded
but
the other part i'm so curious to see
is that first game
that first game is really the first game
you know so we i always talk about week
one the second half is usually a wild
higher scoring affair because guys
haven't played four quarters and in
invariably if you're in shape and you're
in condition or your team has what it
takes you can make a difference in a
higher scoring second half
guys haven't played a snap officials
haven't been on the field for a snap
it is going to be a really bizarre start
to this season
that we don't know if it's going to be
all 16 games if you're gonna get all
eight home games all the other stuff you
talked about so
we are in
if we ever get to focus on the field
which might not be the most important
thing in the world and maybe this year
has made us realize that but when we do
commit to that portion of our lives it's
gonna be a season like we haven't seen
before it's gonna be really hard to
handicap and i think they're gonna be
teams that will surprise you out of
nowhere because they've built something
in their locker room that they can take
to the field and togetherness might
matter a little bit more than how you
run why sticky look and all that stuff
hey mike before we let you go our good
friend turns 40 in two days that's
christopher's birthday do you have any
advice for him for this new chapter in
his life that begins in 48 hours
yeah um you know you will you'll start
to feel it on a regular basis you
complain often
you complain often about how you've oh
this and that but now you're really
really really going to start feeling i
will tell you mike in all this
everything riya's uh during the pandemic
they re-aired a holiday bowl from many
many years ago when young fresh-faced
chris sims threw three
absolute dimes against joey harrington
and oregon at the end of the game and
his receivers didn't come through i will
i will not mention the receivers names
they were young but chris threw three
dimes and they took off his helmet he
was a little upset he took off his
helmet and i said
oh my god he has aged like one year and
15 years
he looks the same at 20 years he looks
exactly the same so that's going to
change chris yeah at least see florio's
gray i've lost my hair
it's going to kind of move across the
screen from this end here it's coming
your way thank you very much thank you
yeah mike gets to hear me complain a lot
on like friday mornings when we're in
notre dame where i'm oh my back hurts oh
i'm tired so it's only gonna get worse
mike okay
and now it's going to be real now you're
not just going to make it up and it's
going to actually be painful
well hey mike thanks as always for some
of your time we know you're busy this
morning it's great insight it's great to
talk to you and we we hope to see you in
person
some way somehow before too long thanks
again stay safe ball the best of your
family we'll talk soon see you mike you
too thanks mike happy birthday sims
thanks buddy okay all right there he is
mike tarico we'll be back to wrap up
this thursday edition of pft live right
after this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports